[Music]
on this Monday night Canadians told to
brace for a wild fire season
as Nova Scotia gets some relief parts of
BC are in danger and an entire Village
in Quebec is decimated the fire was too
strong the calls for a national approach
to extinguish these flames
the backlash against Paul bernardo's
prison transfer Canadians are entitled
to an explanation a push to get one of
Canada's most notorious murderers back
in maximum security
housing construction complications the
need for more homes and the solution in
our backyards
and new Gadget Insight your surroundings
become an infinite canvas apples gamble
as it amps up its augmented reality
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with grim projections
about what is already the worst spring
Wildfire season in Canadian history it
is expected to get worse over the summer
raising questions about whether Canada
has the resources to fight all the fires
here is the picture right now 413 fires
are burning and 26 thousand people have
been forced from their homes fire crews
are doing what they can to get the upper
hand this is a planned ignition at the
Donnie Creek wildfire in northeastern BC
Crews on the ground and in a chopper
using a hella torch are deliberately
starting fires to create a perimeter
around a larger wildfire in order to
contain it in Ontario this fire started
last night about an hour west of Ottawa
forcing more people from their homes
because it's warm and dry in so many
parts of the country it's projected
Canada is on track for the worst ever
year of wildfire destruction we have
complete coverage tonight beginning with
Mike Armstrong
this is the weather most of the country
needs the rain that's fallen in recent
days in Nova Scotia has helped Crews
bring every fire but one under control
at the peak a week ago 16 000 people
were hit with forced evacuations about
two-thirds have now been allowed to go
home pretty weird everything smelled
pretty smoky
I guess we had forgotten a couple
windows open so it smelled pretty bad in
the house now in Quebec the number of
evacuations is still growing 14 000
people have been forced out as fires
threatened several communities there are
154 fires burning 111 are out of control
Premier Monday said the province only
has enough equipment to fight about 30
fires it would normally request help
from other provinces
unfortunately he says they have their
own problems now while it's early in the
season a massive amount of terrain in
Quebec has already been affected the
average for the last 10 years at this
point is 257 hectares burned Quebec is
now already at more than 160
000 hectares one place basically wiped
out according to the premier is the
small village of clova in Northern
Quebec it's a small municipality 36
people unfortunately we weren't able to
save the municipality so the fire was
too strong the smoke from the Quebec
fires is moving south this was the haze
over Ottawa Monday Health authorities
are warning these Smoky air can be
dangerous for people with underlying
conditions Ontario is dealing with its
own evacuations a wildfire that started
Sunday about 150 kilometers west of
Ottawa is burning out of control
now there is international help in
Canada this is a group of South African
firefighters that arrived in Alberta
over the weekend there are close to a
thousand International firefighters and
related Personnel from the U.S Australia
New Zealand and South Africa about 200
more will arrive this week well there
will be work for them BC is dealing with
83 wildfires about 20 are out of control
there is little rain in the forecast and
the last significant rainfall for the
province was a full month ago Mike
Armstrong Global News Halifax
it is impossible to ignore all this
because so many places are vulnerable in
Canada not just stretches of uninhabited
Forest do we have the capacity to deal
with what's coming Eric Sorensen is
looking into that tonight
Canada with its vast forests and
grasslands at a Latitude that is warming
quickly from climate change is facing
among the greatest risks for wildfires
and it's getting ottawa's attention very
early this year this is a scary time our
modeling shows that this may be an
especially severe Wildfire season
throughout the summer the Prime Minister
says Ottawa is coordinating with
provinces training more community-based
firefighters and partnering with
indigenous communities but experts say
Canada's Patchwork of jurisdictional
response needs Improvement we have
different levels of government in Canada
taking various levels of responsibility
we do need to have a national approach
to this that is consistent because these
fires not only affect a province but
they cross borders between provinces
Canada features prominently by every
Wildfire measurement along with Russia
central Africa and the Amazon this is
the annual intensity of wildfires here's
the average annual burned area from Wild
wildfires and the expected burned area
by country Russia and Canada are one and
two facing the highest risk of wildfires
Canada's greatest fire danger right now
is in the west BC Alberta the Northwest
Territories and in the East Ontario and
Quebec Nova Scotia has finally had some
rain but it's been a remarkable year
already Wildland fires consume an
average of 2.5 million hectares annually
this year more than 2.7 million hectares
burned by the end of May 12 times more
than average this early in the season as
fires increasingly threaten both forests
and communities more will need to be
done to coordinate training and response
among Urban and Wildland firefighters it
is an emerging area it is something we
are very live to it is something that
that provinces and territories I think
are increasingly aware of one expert
suggests Canada needs a national
Squadron of firefighting bombers and
Crews that can be deployed the Prime
Minister acknowledged governments must
do more to adapt to the increasing
impacts from climate change more
difficult stating wildfires more intense
hurricanes and storms we are going to
need to continue to step up in our
support for Canadians it's starting off
as one of Canada's worst Wildfire
seasons and the longest days and the
summer heat are still ahead Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
the correctional service of Canada says
it will conduct a review of the decision
to transfer notorious killer and serial
rapist Paul Bernardo to a medium
security facility commissioner Ann Kelly
says the review will check his security
classification to ensure the move is
appropriate and adequately considers the
victims it's unclear why Bernardo was
transferred deserving a life sentence
for kidnapping torturing and murdering
teenagers Kristin French and Leslie
Mahaffey in the 1990s Canada's Public
Safety Minister calls the move
incomprehensible but says his office
cannot overrule it
Canadians find this shocking given the
heinous nature of the crimes that he
committed against women and girls
repeatedly which is why it is important
that she signaled to me that she would
be reviewing the decision
a lawyer for the victim's family says
the decision is devastating and that
bernardo's dangerous offender status
makes the move puzzling the correctional
service of Canada has not explained this
decision it says it can place inmates in
higher security prisons at any point if
deemed necessary to ensure the safety of
the public and institutions
now to that close encounter between a
Chinese warship and an American
destroyer in the Taiwan Strait China has
ramped up its presence in the disputed
East China Sea to conduct what it says
are normal patrols the region is claimed
by both China and Japan and has long
been a point of contention Canada's hmcs
Montreal is there too and our Mackenzie
gray is on board
it's the strongest show of force we've
seen on our trip so far Canadian
Japanese Australian and American ships
all together flying the flag in the East
China Sea Canadian refueling ship MV
Asterix leading the formation as
helicopters Buzz over top taking
pictures of the ships shows our
interoper building our capabilities
together and the fact that we're willing
to work together as separate Nations as
one group photobombing in the background
three Chinese warships their presence
was there but not an impact not
impediment to what we're doing but two
days ago in the Taiwan Strait their
impact was significant the Chinese
warship cutting off USS chung-hoon
the American Navy releasing new video
showing the ships coming within 150
yards of colliding you don't ever want
to be that close to another vessel
because too many things can go wrong and
you can actually have a collision that
Chinese ship a part of the world's
largest navy estimated to have 340
warships recently surpassing the U.S and
dwarfing the 30 ships the Canadian Navy
has
the Chinese build up and other military
drills has the West concern about a
potential invasion of Taiwan across the
very Waters of Montreal sailed just two
days ago Beijing views that
democratically governed Island as a
breakaway territory and despite the
Chinese Communist Party Never
controlling Taiwan the Pentagon believes
president Xi Jinping could order an
attack as soon as 2027. I would argue
that China has actually is already
engaged in a war it's engaged in a Cyber
attack War this is how China and Taiwan
appear on most Maps but this is how the
CCP sees the region that we're sailing
through right now Taiwan is a linchpin
and what Beijing calls the first island
chain a constellation of Western allies
that covered the entire Chinese Coast
but controlling Taiwan would give
Beijing direct access to the Pacific and
to the shipping lanes where nearly 50
percent of global trade is transported
any blockage of that any disruption to
the free flow of Transportation Maritime
Transportation would be incredibly
disruptive to the global economy and
China has a big Edge in controlling that
U.S President Joe Biden has said on four
occasions the Americans would defend
Taiwan from a Chinese attack but the
Canadian defense minister was less clear
Canada backs the one China policy we are
concerned however by China's military
activity in the vicinity of Taiwan and
we urge China to resolve differences
through peaceful needs the Montreal is
scheduled to head to port in Okinawa
later today and that's where we'll be
getting off the boat and heading home
but Donna for many of the sailors on the
Montreal they won't be able to say that
until their deployment's done in October
okay Mackenzie gray near Okinawa Japan
thanks Mackenzie the Russian government
has released video suggesting Ukraine's
much anticipated counter-offensive may
have begun Russia claims it foiled an
assault and claims to have killed up to
300 ukrainians destroying more than 50
military vehicles in the Donetsk region
Ukraine says it has no information about
a large-scale attack there is an
information War as well as a real war
underway President Vladimir zielenski
insists his troops are ready to
recapture occupied territory as Redmond
Shannon reports it appears Ukrainian
soldiers are now making gains near the
destroyed city of bakmut
for Ukraine silence is golden this ad
asks citizens not to post on social
media if they see or hear about military
movements in advance of its
counter-offensive but that offensive may
already be underway the Kremlin posted
this video claiming the operation
started in Failure Sunday with up to 300
ukrainians killed as they attempted an
attack Kiev cryptically said it doesn't
comment on fakes it's unknown when the
videos were taken but they do appear to
be from locations where some experts
predicted an offensive near the
Southeastern corner of the front line
where Ukraine could be aiming to punch
through and split russian-occupied
territory in two as Ministry of Defense
I think stated yesterday there will be
no announcement Ukraine's foreign
minister dimitro culeba very much on
message by saying little but one clue
could lie Elsewhere on the front line
Russia's cantankerous mercenary boss
yevgeni pregosian says Ukraine has
regained land near the destroyed city of
bakmut
a win later loaded by President Vladimir
zielinski at this moment both Moscow and
Kiev do have incentives to spread a bit
of disinformation to confuse the
information space and confuse each other
unverified claims from anti-putin
Russian opposition groups of another
incursion into Russia only add to that
confusion as Moscow defends a 1500
kilometer front line and Kiev looks for
weak spots and so they're going to have
to choose I would think one two maybe
three places where they concentrate that
Force
if the offensive has begun on this the
week of the anniversary of D-Day it
could be a series of small yet brutal
steps rather than one symbolic moment
Redmond Shannon Global News London
which Canadian Airline gets the most
complaints we'll tell you coming up plus
Holmes needed the challenges for
construction companies and a potential
solution
complaints about air travel in Canada
are not unusual these days and according
to new federal data that's especially
true when it comes to Flair Airlines the
Canadian transport agency received
complaints about more than 20 percent of
flare flights during the first quarter
of 2023 by far the worst figure among
Canadian carriers the numbers were about
11 percent of WestJet flights and six
percent of Air Canada flights over the
same time period Flair has been
criticized for poor customer service
last minute cancellations and in some
cases taking passengers to different
airports than their original destination
what's widely expected the Bank of
Canada will hike interest rates again
this week and that will put more
pressure on Canadians struggling to
afford Housing Industry experts warn the
need for affordable housing is quickly
outpacing possible solutions Mike drolet
looks at one idea that can be found
right in our backyards
foreign
no matter how fast these homes go up
there's a very real possibility it won't
be fast enough to meet demand we have a
plan to double home building over the
next decade for people at all income
levels the federal government has put a
number on what is needed 2.5 million
homes built over the next decade put
another way that's a finished home every
two minutes what are the chances the
construction industry thinks it can pull
it off yeah zero no chance at all no
chance at all
if you took all the construction workers
across Canada landscape everything like
that they'd all have to come to Ontario
just to meet Ontario's goal complicating
matters three levels of government that
have to be in sync Ontario for one tried
to spur on the construction industry by
waiving development charges for Builders
municipalities aren't happy because they
need those fees to build sewers and
Roads one tier of government is saying
you can't build here then you are
nimby's not in my backyard then you have
counselors who are nymptus not in my
term of office then you have the crazies
called bananas build absolute nothing
anywhere near anything with all those
issues at play Guelph Ontario startup
packed homes is pushing another option
come in here they're called adus or
accessory dwelling units smaller homes
built on existing properties most often
for relatives or rental units where a
traditional home can take up to two
years to build adus can be erected in as
little as five weeks because everything
is prefabricated packed homes offers a
585 square foot unit for two hundred and
thirty five thousand dollars do you
think this is the game changer I do I do
I think it's the Tesla of house billing
they've become hugely popular in San
Francisco as well as in Toronto and
Vancouver Alleyways so why haven't we
seen more of them Built Well just like
every other suggestion to address the
housing crisis not everyone wants them
in their neighbor's backyard microlight
Global News Toronto
students satellites ahead the Canadian
cargo on its way to the International
Space Station
[Music]
go falcon go dragon
this is the latest cargo Mission from
SpaceX taking off of the International
Space Station and among the 3 000 plus
kilograms of supplies and Provisions are
Canadian made cubesats there are many
cube-shaped satellites the Canadian
University students built and designed
over the last five years they're about
the size of a Rubik's Cube and will each
perform a different Mission lasting
about a year they'll study things like
climate change weather and radiation
in Virginia no survivors were found at
the crash site of a small plane that
flew into restricted airspace near
Washington D.C
two f-16s were scrambled to intercept
the plane Sunday afternoon triggering a
sonic boom over the city military Pilots
tried to contact the Cessna multiple
times and set off flares but determined
the pilot was incapacitated the fighter
jets stayed with the civilian aircraft
until it crashed in a remote mountainous
area four people were on board Federal
investigators are now trying to figure
out what happened
Prince Harry was a no-show for his
highly anticipated phone hacking lawsuit
in the UK today Harry was expected in
court for the first day of his case
against the publisher of the Daily
Mirror tabloid he claims the paper
invaded his privacy by hacking his cell
phone lawyers for the publisher say
there's no evidence his phone was hacked
the Duke of Sussex is scheduled to take
the stand tomorrow
virtual Vision next Apple's expensive
Endeavor into augmented reality
[Music]
when he first put on Vision Pro you see
your space and everything in it there's
something truly extraordinary about
seeing your favorite apps and
experiences right there in the room with
you
Apple has unveiled it's much anticipated
augmented reality headset it's not the
first player in the game and apple is
banking on a sector that is struggling
things don't come cheap at Apple a
headset will cost nearly five thousand
dollars Canadian the question is will
enough consumers buy it Jeff Semple
reports
the company that built its trillion
dollar brand by producing game-changing
technology announced its first new
product in a decade introducing Apple
Vision Pro Apple's mixed reality headset
unveiled at the company's annual
developers conference Blends the real
world with the digital
this marks the beginning of a journey
that will bring a new dimension to
powerful personal technology the headset
marks Apple's first foray into virtual
and augmented reality but the technology
which produces a 3D interactive
environment has been around for years
used for everything from video games
to training astronauts to travel into
space even soldiers to fight in Ukraine
I'll try not to hit you or anything
Victor Global News recently visited this
startup in Kiev that's piloting VR Tech
to train ukrainians to fire mortars it's
a learning process it's a process of
experiencing something but despite its
many successes VR has so far failed to
live up to the hype so I think it has a
lot of potential this VR researcher says
the technology is still buggy and there
aren't a lot of real world applications
and so we've gotten really far
um it's just there's there's a ways to
go since releasing the iPod back in 2001
Apple has created an entire ecosystem of
products that whether you like it or not
have become ubiquitous but for some
analysts who were expecting the next big
leap the headset is a bit of a head
scratcher Tech Giants Google meta and
Microsoft have all tried and failed in
some cases spectacularly to turn VR into
a money-making reality there we go this
industry analyst spoke to us over zoom
using his VR headset which produces an
avatar good-looking Avatar right you've
got there I made myself a little bit
Slimmer he imagines a not too distant
future where these headsets will allow
people to appear physically in a room
together meeting playing and
collaborating when Apple comes into a
market it really pushes the boundaries
it makes things cool
and it really creates some consumer Buzz
he says Apple's first headset is just
the beginning analysts say the device
with its eye-watering price tag is too
expensive and impractical though that's
also what they said about the first
iPhone
Jeff Semple Global News Toronto
I don't want to talk to an avatar that
is global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's year in Canada
is this Canada goose in her goslings
chilling in Edmonton we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you